good evening and welcome to the 46th
annual Student Academy Awards thinking
back to that first ceremony in 1973 it's
hard to imagine that we had an American
president under investigation
the nation was facing a recession and
the Dodgers weren't going to the World
Series
how things have changed the truth is
over those decades some wonderful things
gratefully have remained constant the
importance of these awards what they
mean not just to the winners but to our
entire film community and also our
commitment to support and encourage
excellence in filmmaking at the
collegiate level for tonight's honorees
this is just a first step no one knows
what opportunities await you but for
some of you perhaps all you were on the
same path as past student Academy Award
winners who have gone on to receive 62
Oscar nominations and have won or shared
12 Awards
you should all be very proud of your
passion for your art and the talents
you've shared with us simply put you are
the future of film a future that is
diverse international and in every sense
extraordinarily bright on behalf of all
the members of the Academy we can't wait
to see the stories you next tale
congratulations I would also like to
thank the 752 Academy members who served
as judges of the submissions from
students everywhere from Prague Czech
Republic to Provo Utah to Guangzhou
China we literally could not do this
without you and it is now my give it up
and now it's my pleasure to introduce an
Academy member who is a pioneer in
digital marketing the founder of
Hollywood in pixels a nonprofit
promoting protecting and preserving our
industry's vast digital history she is
now paving a new future of movie
marketing through the lens of data at
Warner Brothers please welcome the chair
of the Student Academy Awards Executive
Committee
Bettina sharukh
[Applause]